my my goal for documenting this is to
show that these are extremely
experimental and we don't know what
we're doing because we are trying to uh
create function and create appearance in
a person where that's not natural
whereas medicine is supposed to be about
reform restoring a person's natural
functioning and preserving it
not not a trying to put wings on someone
to see if it works which is essentially
what we're doing
[Music]
hello and welcome to trigonometry i'm
francis foster i'm constantine kissinger
and this is a show for you if you want
honest conversations with fascinating
people our brilliant guest today has
been banned from youtube so here is
excellencic for excellence welcome to
trigonometry thank you so much i'm so
glad to be here i've been really looking
forward to this uh it's great to have
you on the show i can tell you a lot of
our fans particularly the female ones
have been looking to this forward to
this as well uh tell us who are you how
are you where you are why is everyone so
looking forward to hearing us interview
you
uh so so my name is excellency as you
said and uh i have been uh making
content related to the uh the trans
zeitgeist for the past year
uh and uh the way that i make content is
that i find uh largely personal
narratives
and i respond to them point by point uh
and try to give a medical context for
the horrific nightmares that they're
living through
and explain how these are very
predictable
and uh i'm seeking to kind of educate
the audience uh uh in a way that uh i
don't know if you ever saw the show
daria but i feel like my my channel my
my content mimics uh the show in within
that show called sick sad world
uh so so um
in any case
uh i also have made a lot of responses
to the show i am jazz uh and uh the uh
main star of that show had a
vaginoplasty when he was 17 after having
his puberty suppressed for many years
uh and then i'm also have been looking
at the uh the medical industry and
specific doctors and responding to uh
their
comments and their advertisements on
tick tock and just generally attempting
to
raise the alarm that these are very very
bad uh interventions that are being
given to people
on the basis of their mental illness and
so i think a lot of people are excited
to hear you interview me because uh they
didn't realize that this was going on uh
or they lived through it and and uh or
they they narrowly missed falling into
it and are grateful for that
um so
and do you have a some kind of personal
connection with this issue uh yes i do i
was uh uh trans identifying for about
four years in college uh i went to uh
university of california berkeley which
is where uh judith butler teaches and so
is very much steeped in gender ideology
uh and and the different interpretations
on it
uh and so i've used that as a kind of a
basis for talking about the more
religious elements
and the different doctrinal splits that
have emerged between uh like what i've
been calling trans classic and and uh
the church of the non-binaries
uh so so uh
uh i was uh
very much steeped in that my social
circle was steeped in that i was a
gender and women's studies major and so
i was i was that was just my life for
several years and i watched
some friends transition and i saw the
reality of it
and uh
then i went to graduate school and i
studied uh
speech and language pathology and part
of that is is studying uh pronouns and
pronoun disorders
and so as a clinician i treat pronoun
disorders i treat people who've had
brain injuries and they can use other
words but they can't use pronouns
anymore and i want them to be safe at
work i don't want them to be harassed at
work when they get back into work and
these pronoun policies and expectations
are very unreasonable and don't take
disability into account
and
before we get in into the clinical
aspect a bit let's just look at your
journey
what made you identify as trans for four
years
was there a particular moment was there
or was it
always a general discomfort with your
body
i i feel like i had a general discomfort
both with the with my body and with the
social expectations that were put on me
for being female
uh and then i also feel like uh from
early childhood a lot that discomfort
was largely rooted in in an early
childhood uh trauma had a significant
injury
and i think i just felt very alienated
and i think i looked for an explanation
and the explanation i landed on was it
would be different if i was a boy
and uh
that was just kind of at the back of my
mind
uh and
coming out in you know immature ways
because i was a child and then i grew up
and and uh
got to college and was exposed to these
ideas was exposed to all these people
saying yeah me too were the same and it
was just like oh okay great i can
finally like pursue this in some way
uh and and it was also just kind of the
thing to do everyone was doing it
um and
you said everyone was doing it so then
how did it
then move on to something more serious
did you have a medical procedures did
you take uh any type of
how can i put these hormones in order to
facilitate a transition
i i uh took um a kind of hormone to
affect
my menstrual cycles but i didn't take
testosterone fortunately and i didn't do
anything else which is i'm so grateful
for
so so i didn't take anything that would
permanently change me and the reason i
didn't is because i had a non-gender
therapist a real therapist who was able
to help me talk through
my feelings about it as well as likely
outcomes of pursuing a medical
intervention and i was able to really
think about it with somebody that wasn't
trying to push me down the assembly line
and i was able to see that like you know
this is this would introduce so much
unpredictable horror like into my life
if i was good to pursue a surgery
um so it was a process of talking about
it with my therapist over a period of
months
and as you can see we're trying to take
this conversation in a direction where
people who are not clued up on this
issue nearly as much as you are can can
understand what we're talking about
because we've been talking about it for
for some time but even we i would
certainly not consider ourselves experts
in this era at all um
so i suppose the sort of question that
many people
many people would be asking because the
general perception i think among most
people who are uninitiated in this issue
is there are some people who feel that
they are in the wrong body
they are not the sex in which they were
physically born
and we as a society have come to a point
where we now have the medical toolkit to
support those people
into making changes to their body
that make them feel more comfortable
with who they are quote unquote that
would be i think the mainstream
description of of the trans
position what is incorrect about that
view in your opinion
don't say everything
i mean the uh first thing is that uh to
be born into a body you need to believe
in a material
or some kind of immaterial essence that
exists apart from the body that can be
then placed into the body and that's
generally considered a soul and so we
we're dealing with a religious concept
here um to to be born in the wrong body
and then the second part of that is like
well medical science can now change it
uh my my goal for documenting this is to
show that these are extremely
experimental and we don't know what
we're doing because we are trying to uh
create function and create appearance in
a person where that's not natural
whereas medicine is supposed to be about
reform restoring a person's natural
functioning and preserving it uh not not
not uh trying to put wings on someone to
see if it works which is essentially
what we're doing
it's a great point what effect do these
therapies have particularly because you
can talk about it from your own
experience
but also the therapies that you thank
the lord avoided
uh so the the
the one i needed it turned out that that
i have a sensitivity to estrogen and so
i had noticed that and then i had made
inferences about it and i had i had uh
wanted to to to to address it so i i got
very uh fortunate in in that i was able
to be observant and make those kind of
inferences and that i happen to also
just have that sensitivity for an
unrelated medical problem that i didn't
know i had at the time and now i do so i
i just you know it worked and i'm glad
that that was
all i did the testosterone the thing
about testosterone is that it is a very
powerful anxiety reliever
and so i watched it work really really
well to relieve untreated anxiety issues
in a person that i was close to
and it was the first thing they tried
and they didn't try anything else and it
did all these other changes to her
so those changes that are happening in
the voice
when you're taking testosterone and it
makes their voice drop those changes are
happening because those tissues are
sensitive to testosterone and
testosterone makes them grow but your
voice is not the only place those
tissues exist those tissues are also in
a lot of very important organs
like the heart and so so my concern is
that we're you know we we know that that
testosterone increases your risk of
heart events that's known when men die
earlier of causes they don't they don't
they don't just expire because that's
what what their due dates had on them
when they came out so so they die of
specific ways and they typically die of
heart problems and and it's well
acknowledged by these people that trans
men are shortening their life spans by
doing this by taking these drugs
and the theory as well it's not shorter
than a regular man which there's no
evidence for and there's significant
evidence against that claim
um
the fact remains there they're giving
these teenagers drugs that will shorten
their lifespan and they know it
for for a mental health issue
and puberty blockers is something that
we hear a lot and young people taking
them now obviously
i i'm not a physician but the moment
that i hear that they're giving kids
puberty blockers to stop them going
through puberty
is horrendous and awful could you
explain a little bit of what it's like
when you're on puberty blockers
and number two not just that what are
the long-term implications of taking
puberty blockers right
uh so puberty blockers are a class of
drugs called gonadotropin-releasing
hormones or hormone analogues uh and so
the one that they give
that i'm most familiar with that should
be lupron but they give several others
now uh is is uh i believe 20 times as
powerful as the version that your body
makes
and the version that your body makes
works by
developing certain structures in the
brain
which then release other hormones that
cause the gonads to develop which then
release other hormones that cause the
secondary sex characteristics to develop
so so basically we are we are putting
the pollution in the water very far
upstream from where it was and more
towns are going to be affected as a
result
so so uh the way that this hormone works
in the body is that it has a pulsing
uh release
that causes it to grow kind of like how
plants grow because of pulsing exposure
to sunlight you have you have day night
day night it's pulsing
and so that pulsing is is um
not happening if you use a puberty
blocker implant because it's a
continuous slow release
and that's the way that they work is
that they interrupt the pulsation that
pulsing is a very complex pattern that
changes according to things like time of
day and time of year
so so it's doing a lot it's they they're
they're putting their brains in a dark
room so that they can't grow
and leaving them there and and and it
causes uh profound implications and so
one thing i've talked about with i am
jazz a lot is that my suspicion is that
his the puberty blocker implants uh
warped the development of this
hypothalamus
uh and we know that there's a and we we
we can infer a lot about how drugs work
or might work from comparing them to
genetic disorders that do similar things
and there's a genetic disorder called
prader-willi syndrome which jazz
jennings does not have of course there's
no reason to think he has it
but i believe that they have induced
similar effects by uh using
a drug that mimics the
hormone that is affected in that that
condition
and that hormone that that condition is
caused by uh effect it affects the gene
that codes for gonadotropin releasing
hormone
this causes damage to the hypothalamus's
development and that causes uh
overeating
uh and and so jazz jennings is really
struggling with with uh eating he's very
very obese right now because he can't
stop eating
and uh so so it um that condition
desensitizes basically the hypothalamus
to oxytocin and so therefore they can't
um they don't get the comfort of
comforting reinforcement of the eating
and and why is it that
we trivialize this excellencic why is it
the
this is seen as something
good that you know that if if if a child
is suffering from gender dysphoria if
you're putting them on puberty blockers
you're doing the right and kind thing
when what you are doing and what like
you've just said yourself is
irreversibly damaging their body yeah
it's horrendous it is and it and it
affects their bone health too because
you need those sex hormones especially
estrogen to to develop bone density
because uh um
you know your bones are growing and when
they grow your the volume and density is
changing and therefore unless you have
something to increase the rate that it
can become dense
they will not become dense and so we
know that these these lead to things
like osteoporosis
early in life 20s and 30s for kids that
were put on them as children and not
even for the years that they're putting
them on them now for the puberty
blockade they're put just just for you
know a few months for for things like uh
um precocious puberty uh and so i
believe your question was why why is it
seen as soon as there's been a huge
propaganda push and there's a lot of
money behind this telling people it's
reversible you know you are you're uh
this way you're not forcing them to go
through their natural puberty
uh which is to me an acknowledgement
that we're playing god here we know we
know that we're trying to change nature
uh and we're not we're not trying to
heal we're trying to actually control
and and and so so uh you know i'm an
atheist i don't object to playing god on
principle but here clearly it's causing
a lot of harm
hey francis have you decided what to get
your dad for father's day same thing as
always a couple of pints down the dog
and duck plus a new brexit means brexit
car sticker to replace the one i got him
last year mate brexit was in 2016. do
you not think he might want something a
bit more up to date like a new ridge
wallet this is mine it's smooth sleek
stylish and it can hold 12 cards and
there's also a clip on the back for cash
as well it's not going to create a bulge
in your trousers like those bulky old
wallets it'll make your dad look like a
top level player
great idea he can also put his brick
stick sticker on it which means a
problematic older ladies are gonna love
him
yeah okay the great thing about ridge is
that they give you a lifetime guarantee
which means if you want you can have
just one wallet for the rest of your
life rich is so confident in their
product they'll give you 45 days to test
drive their wallet that means you can
get the wallet use it and if you don't
like it you can return it in 45
days unlike brexit
because ridge are such great guys
they're going to give you 15 off and
free worldwide shipping and returns
that's 15 percent off and free worldwide
shipping and returns to take advantage
of this incredible offer go to ridge.com
forward slash trigger that's ridge.com
forward slash trigger and use our
special promo code which is of course
trigger
why do you think
this has been
uh mainstreamed so rapidly to the point
now
where i think a lot of people the the
version of the story i i presented to
you at the beginning
about how there are some people who are
born in the wrong body how did that
become such a mainstream thing to the
point where we've had laws changed to
accommodate this version of events uh
we've had uh you know we have the
tavistock clinic here in the uk that
that was doing a lot of this type of
stuff
how has this become such a mainstream
thing
it's a really good question because it's
it it's it's
seems like people should know better i
feel like we are living through um
something similar to the satanic panic
of the 80s and so so there's kind of a
moral panic here that there are all
these kids that were that were destined
to self-harm or end their lives and
because of our our lack of recognition
and now we have a chance to do the right
thing and so so there's there's kind of
a moral panic and there's a mass
hysteria too and the mass hysteria the
mass delusion is is that you can be born
in the wrong body you know this this
idea that there is this class of people
that need need these things
and you don't agree with that you don't
think anyone can be born in the wrong
body
no i think you're born as the body you
are i i think that you your
consciousness is an emergent property of
your brain and is is secondary to the
brain i don't i don't think that your
consciousness is placed there by a deity
people can disagree i don't think that
this secular government can uh write
laws on the basis of the theory that
there there are souls that can be in the
wrong body and therefore i need to use
pronouns that pretend that i believe
that they have a different kind of soul
than they clearly seem to have based on
their body
because they don't believe in souls
do you think part of the problem
exorantic is this
i think it's fair to say and i think the
vast majority of people would agree that
in the 80s and the 70s
we made a dreadful dreadful mess of gay
rights where
gay men and gay women went through a
horrendous time they went through a
horrendous time it was awful and there
was a real struggle for them to be
acknowledged on the same level as other
people in society and
thank god
the vast majority of people now see them
that way
do you think people are looking at this
trans rights issue and thinking to
themselves hang on we messed up so badly
before
that this is a new gay rights movement
yeah i don't want to be seen as one of
those horrible people
telling uh gay people that they had no
right to exist
yeah yeah so they're it's waving them
through they're saying we don't want to
go through that again hurry up just come
on in
but but what we're dealing with though
is is a group that is aggressively
mimicking uh the gay rights struggle
copying our language copying our
experience and then turning around and
saying that we are bigots for not uh
wanting uh cro to sleep with the
opposite sex
uh that that is transphobic and that
we're bad for saying that we only want
to sleep with females there was the
reason i started speaking out was the
there was a huge debacle on uh tick tock
last march where a guy had posted a
video saying that he was only attracted
to females who were born female and he
was calling it super straight
and and
the whole app went nuts and we had all
of these adults
pretending that they had never heard of
homosexuality and so i just started
being like speaking out and be like no i
my my sexual orientations is like a like
a dousing rod it's like i can tell i can
tell that they're not women and i'm not
going to pretend that i think that
they're women
but
isn't the problem as well that
there are trans people you know there
are people who have suffering from some
from gender dysphoria who feel a severe
discomfort in their own body
and what is happening with the
politicization of their identity is
these people are being turned into
political pawns which is just making the
the entire situation worse for them
uh
i uh yeah i agree with that that there
there are people that would just prefer
to like live their lives and they they
might want to dress in a way that is
gender non-conforming or adopt a
non-traditional name
or this or that
i don't think it's ethical for doctors
to participate by by attempting to
medicalize their mental illness in that
way
despite the known
effects on other on organs
i've and i've said this too that that
some of these people you know there's
there's a lot of propaganda push that
that you need specific trans rights and
trans people are protected in employment
trans people are protected in housing i
totally disagree with that i feel like
they're already clearly well protected
under many existing uh categories
including religion disability sex and
sexuality and so i don't understand why
these forces are propagandizing trans
people that they don't have rights they
could assert if their landlord's
discriminating against them under those
categories
uh so so i think that they are
manipulating mentally ill people into
thinking that they are much more
oppressed and much more marginalized
than they are and these are people who
are already very anxious perhaps because
a doctor gave them a drug that blocked
testosterone and they're male and they
need testosterone and that makes them
anxious
because we know that lack of
testosterone makes men anxious
you keep uh
and this is going to sound like a stupid
question but uh i'm asking in order
knowing that there will be a lot of
people asking in their heads watching
and listening to this which is you keep
referring to
uh
to gender dysphoria as a mental illness
yes
why why do you say that because again
the mainstream narrative would be well
people are just born this way and this
is how they feel inside
yeah uh so the thing is that that that
we're also told though that that
this is a situation where the person can
be reasonably expected to self-harm or
try to end their life if we don't
intervene and and
mentally well people aren't trying to
hurt themselves or end their life that's
not a mentally well thing to do
it's a very very confused
self-sabotaging
uh thing to do
and and i'm not saying that i don't
understand what it's like to feel that
way i certainly do but it's not a sign
of mental health to want to do that and
so if i'm told that this group has this
extremely high likelihood 41 i've been
told of wanting to try to do that that's
a sign of mental distress and so when
when you have this any sort of chronic
mental distress that really impacts your
life to me that's when it rises to the
level of a mental illness
and and
there's unless you have good evidence
that you have a physiological problem
you should treat it as a mental illness
well i suppose the argument from people
who are in favor of uh helping people
transition is uh that the transitioning
alleviates the distress
and you know we've had people on the
show uh we've had a lot of trans people
on the show who are uh gender critical
but we've also had at least one person
on the show who had transitioned and was
very happy to have transitioned
so the argument i suppose goes is there
are some people like that for whom not
not just one in fact we had several so
buck angel for example um
who was i think he's very happy to have
transitioned uh india will it be again
so um isn't it the case that for some
people this is a solution that solves
their problems
uh so the the
there's a couple things with that one
would be the existence of the placebo
effect if you uh take a substance and
expect it to help you uh you will likely
experience some subjective benefit from
that
uh
and uh placebo effect is a real chemical
effect we can we can block it with
certain certain drugs that i believe the
ones that block opioid receptors will
block the placebo effect there's other
drugs that will potentiate it so it's a
real effect so we have that issue that
these these drugs may just be placebos
maybe they just needed a regular placebo
because they're mentally ill and so they
needed to believe that they were being
treated for their non-illness in order
to not experience the symptoms of the
mental illness
and so at that point you're like is it
is it justified could there be have been
a better placebo that didn't cause them
to have heart disease and die several
years earlier than they would have or in
buck angel's case i believe a buck had a
sepsis
from from the
vaginal atrophy from the testosterone
and also nearly died from that and so
there's a huge community pressure
against regretting these interventions
and so they don't they vote very vocally
are very happy about them if they want
to remain a church member in good
standing
um
so uh uh
and then and then finally as i mentioned
the things like testosterone estrogen
they they can have um they're having
metabolic effects in the brain we know
that and we know that they can interact
with anxiety and other things so it's
very possible that that they are
treating a men's a physical illness
and or using it as a psychotropic mental
in this treatment
and anxiety reliever and that's why
their life is better on it and again
we're back to
was there a better way that didn't cause
these other problems that are then going
to burden society
with these issues like i have having to
take care of some of these these
complications
in a nursing home in a person who's you
know several decades down the road and
and these problems didn't go away that
they acquired in their 20s i interviewed
somebody that that underwent
vaginoplasty or sorry phalloplasty at a
children's hospital and vaginectomy and
the vaginectomy was so so botched that
that this person ended up with a um a
colostomy bag
from it
right so based on that then am i hearing
you correctly that you if it were up to
you
people would not be transitioning they
would be getting some kind of talk
talking therapy
to help them deal with the mental
illness of
feeling like they're in the wrong body
but they wouldn't be getting any
physical or hormonal
help if you like if you can call it help
uh so the
i i would not not agree with that
because um we we use medications to
treat mental illnesses at times what i
want is for these patients to have the
full range of options and not be told
that what this specific mental illness
means that that only this one specific
treatment will help because there's not
really any evidence for that we have
we've never done a placebo-controlled uh
double-blinded trial of whether
mastectomies make you feel better
because we can't do a sham mastectomy
we can't pretend to do a mastectomy and
see if they feel better anyway
they're going to know the doctors are
going to know we can't do a double blind
trial these aggressive radical
interventions are justified in terms of
cancer because we know that the cancer
is about to kill them so it's okay to do
these things that don't have
double-blinded controlled trials because
there's still a reasonable reason to
think it'll help
we don't have that for here we're trying
to cut out the feelings cancer it
doesn't it doesn't work
um so but but whereas uh if if they're
getting a comprehensive intervention uh
hormonal modification may be a part of
it i do not believe that cross-sex
hormones at cross-sex doses are
clinically justified for mental illness
now i don't think there's any evidence
for that however i know that for my case
that that i personally benefited from a
hormonal intervention that was not
across sex hormone uh to modify
something that turned out to be a
physical uh illness and and and so i i
wouldn't borrow at wholesale because
these hormones have profound effects in
the brain
um for for both sexes uh even the sex
hormones that are associated with your
sex can be
affecting your mental health so so i i
don't i wouldn't want to say that having
gender dysphoria precludes certain
options either
but these options are bad these options
are very bad and unjustified
and was there a specific moment for you
where you were
in your period as a trans person where
you actually thought hang on
this is
a right there's something not right here
that
basically put you on the path to
recovery as it were mentally
yeah it was a few things uh
one was that um the speed that that
someone i i was very close with went
from uh her first appointment with the
gender therapist to a mastectomy that
was very concerning it was about eight
months i felt like that was way too fast
um at her age she was like 21 and and
had no history of it like it was all it
was like a totally rapid onset because
she met me of all things and i and i
introduced her to the concept
and
then she had a head injury
uh she's hit by car
and so everyone knew everyone all of her
doctors knew she went to the hospital
she was overnight it was well known
and they still let her go through with
it a couple months later
you know she needed she needed actual
therapy to deal with the head injury uh
i do brain injury therapy now she need
she needed concussion therapy and they
just they just waved her through and uh
i watched that recovery i was i was very
close right up in the aftermath watched
her drain her
blood bags watched her chest feed a bag
that was attached to it through a tube
and and
it just was i could just tell it just
wasn't right it was this person was was
engaged in a pursuit of
uh religious ecstasy and then and then
they got the real the real turning point
for me was when uh she got really upset
that she came across a study for an hiv
drug that was about preventing
transmission between uh gay men or men
men who were sleeping with men at least
and um
she thought that she deserved to be in
the trial because she was on
testosterone and that made her a man now
and and
it was just so unreasonable i was like
no you're not you're not male and it's
really important for drug research that
we have a male research trial and a
female research trial because when you
treat females as a kind of male females
die from the drugs
because we're not men we're
categorically different our biology is
very different
wow
and what happened to this person
uh we we kind of a lost touch uh after
i i went off to grad school we tried to
stay in touch a little bit but then but
then
lost touch so i'm not exactly sure what
happened to her um after that i know
that she went on to to kind of get a
uh stuck working for some trans
organization i think so so but
i worry about her i don't i don't know
what happened after that
and these people who transition and then
decide to detransition what are their
lives like excellent sick i know they're
a broad group but on the whole were
there any patterns or correlations that
you
well the the ones that i've talked to uh
there's certainly a lot of uh uh sadness
about uh
the permanent changes to their voice
um and and uh um or s in some cases more
semi-permanent because they're really
they're there it's very unpredictable
uh what kinds of sensitivity you have in
your voice and they're giving them very
random doses some of these doctors for
for random lengths of time so it's it
can be very unpredictable how it'll
affect them
um and then there there's other bodily
changes that are permanent um genitalia
changes that could be permanent after
testosterone so there's there's a lot of
just regret a lot of people saying they
didn't nobody told them a lot of these
things
um
and uh uh sadness uh having undergone a
mastectomy after just a couple months
because they were in their first ever
manic episode
and nobody slowed them down because of
the cultural belief that if you have
this specific preoccupation you know
it's never anything else it's always
standalone it's always clearly point a
to point b you just need this and you'll
be fine it's a very simplistic model
um
i'll be honest with you because i i used
to be a teacher so i've taught kids
for many years for 12 years and towards
the end of my career i started to notice
kids saying that they were you know
gender non-conforming that they were
non-binary
and and i looked at a lot of these kids
and
my initial reaction was like no you're
just a gay kid
you're just gay and that's difficult to
come to terms with it is you know it is
you know and you know it's so hard
yeah it's even in 2022 it's not easy
particularly when all you want to do as
a kid is fit in
do you think that's part of the problem
yeah no i it was it's really hard for me
to come out really really hard uh and i
wanted there to be another way and it
makes sense it makes sense like oh maybe
i'm just supposed to be a boy i also
like it at the time i was very uh
i thought of it as like that you you
learn a social language from other
people by watching them and you kind of
do but the problem with that theory was
the idea that you would only learn one
or the other sexist patterns or that
there was one set of binary patterns
that you'd pick one or the other it's
like it's it's obviously it's just
shared a dialogue and you know that's
kind of the basis of drag for instance
is is this taking on the other other
person's uh
uh way of uh you know behavioral speech
patterns if you will and so so um
i i fully agree that there's there's a
lot of confusion
when you're growing up as a gay kid in a
society that's that's very
heteronormative and and you're you
you're watching all this media as a
child and the person that you want to be
with only wants to be with the other sex
and so it's it's confusing and it's hard
and so you you come up with other
reasons why you don't have to be the
embarrassing thing of being gay
and and you know
eventually you have to kind of come to
terms but at the time in in college like
you know i i was i was trying to date
a man who was
trans feminine on the theory that
you know it was good enough he was a
very feminine man very very familiar
but no it's not the same it's just not
it doesn't work
because whenever i speak to people about
this the first people that i spoke to
who were raising the alarm about this
were actually gay women
what do you think it is in particular
about
gay women who
were the first ones to notice it were
the first ones to raise alarm were the
first ones to really talk about this
uh i think a few things um one is that
that uh lesbians are targeted by the
trans-identifying men a lot more than
men are targeted by trans-identifying
women it does happen especially lately
it seems more and more that we're having
trans-identifying women identifying as
gay men and then going and harassing gay
men for not wanting to to be with them
but i feel like that was at least
initially more of a problem of men
towards lesbians uh and and so that's
why we saw it more there i think we also
like
puberty is physically uncomfortable if
you're a female and so i think it's
we're more likely to to feel a bit
alienated and dissociated from our
bodies as a result of that
uh just just everything that's that's
growing and changing just hurts on a
physical level so
um
i think that that it was perhaps easier
for for women to understand why why the
rapid onset thing would appeal to women
um from the statistics i've seen it
seems like the
uh
girls are are making up the bulk of
these referrals
these days it's it and that's that's
represented a real shift um
away from from the past and uh
and also just just just
the reality of of uh
[Music]
female-only spaces and and and uh being
being victimized by voyeurs and flashers
and you know all these things just make
us more
aware of the fact that of male predators
and being uh
gay you know there's no there's no
confusion
about like i didn't want that i didn't i
didn't want this interaction
i was not sending signals
no signals were sent
and i told you i don't want males
that's a really interesting point that i
haven't heard before but it makes so
much sense
makes a lot of sense and you mention the
rapid onset stuff i mean
whichever position you're coming out
this issue from i think the one thing
that everybody would accept is this
issue is shot up to prominence and
partly that is not only the coverage of
it but it's also the sheer numbers have
changed completely in the last few years
why has that happened
i have a few things i think uh well
covet i think has been a huge huge issue
um uh that's something that that i i did
a review of a five-person panel from
boston children's hospital which is the
hospital that did the vaginectomy on the
person that i interviewed that i just
was discussing i ended up with the
colostomy bag and in that interview they
were saying that oh well they think
their theory was that everyone was at
home during covid and they all just felt
safer to come out i think that
everyone's home at cobit on tiktok and
they all were bored and they thought of
something that would be interesting and
they thought of a scavenger hunt that
would be fun to pursue
um so so i think that was part of it
everybody was just kind of you know home
thinking about it i also think uh uh you
know the one of the the manufacturers of
the one of the puberty blockers got in
trouble
uh a number of years ago for for paying
doctors to prescribe them
uh for for their uh precocious puberty
so i just feel like there's there's a
huge amount of money behind this and we
it came out uh in the last couple weeks
that like the nhs i believe is is also
starting to pay doctors per patient
for prescribing the cross-sex hormones
um so i don't know whether that
specifically they know about that with
puberty blockers but it wouldn't
wouldn't surprise me um if the
manufacturer was doing that at least
privately
but why are more people presenting with
this with this issue
i think that they've heard about it and
and it seems like an explanation that
makes sense and it makes their distress
not their fault and therefore not really
their responsibility
uh and it makes it other people's fault
and it's an opportunity to uh kind of
control other people around you
uh and and regain a sense of control
that way um but i think the big thing is
that it's popular it's all over social
media
uh and um
[Music]
that there's there's there's a lot of
money behind it i've also seen a video
where it was a um
a young person on tick tock i think they
said they were 14 or 15 and they said
that the doctor had actually called
their parents and direct marketed uh
puberty blockers uh to the child on the
basis of the fact that the doctor
thought the child had gender dysphoria
based on the child's outfit based on the
child's preference for a baseball cap
and a collared shirt and and the child
said that she hadn't heard of that
before but it made a lot of sense and
that she was mad because her parents
were mad and said no but she was gonna
still try to figure out how to get on it
and this was supposed to tick-tock
by the child
so
right so you basically got a tomboy who
walks into a doctor's office and works
walks out with a prescription yeah
and and uh so obviously they're gonna be
targeting uh uh lesbians
disproportionately uh who are a bit
uncomfortable with the fact that that
they don't look like the group that that
is attract that that the group that they
wanna be with is attracted to you know
it's it's it's i feel like normal and
natural i'm not saying any any any girl
that that dresses in like a tomboy is
gay uh but but if you go after the
tomboys you're going to get a lot of
gays you're going to get a lot of
lesbians
yeah and it also makes sense if someone
appears you know if it's a woman who
appears more masculine
uh than the average female or the other
way a boy who appears more feminine than
the average boy
inevitably they're gonna feel more
uncomfortable with their bodies because
they don't feel that they're conforming
which then means they're then going to
be put at risk of transitioning
yeah particularly in your teenage years
and let's talk about autism because i
feel that this is something that we
don't talk about enough
i read a stat i think it was 35 of all
people or children who transition are
autistic or have been identified as
having autism wow
now that to me
is just a horrifying stat
can you can you talk a little bit about
that what is the link between autism and
gender dysphoria are we seeing more kids
with autism uh being put through this
path
uh sure yeah i'm happy to talk about
that so so
um autism has two main components which
would be the sensory component and the
social pragmatic component and the
social pragmatic component would be
social language social thinking theory
of mind understanding other people and
why they do what they do and so as a
speech pathologist i treat
sociopragmatic disorders and so i treat
a lot of autistic kids i don't i don't
diagnose autism but i treat the social
pragmatic component of it if it's
present um and with autism that's that's
core diagnostic so it's present
and um so so
the issue with that is that they don't
understand
how these interactions unfold and so
they're very very more likely to think
that they have to look a certain way for
them to unfold
correctly like they don't they don't get
it they don't get why people are like
that and they want they want to have
successful interactions and they get in
their head that they need to be the
other sex perhaps because they're gay
and they have only seen those kinds of
interactions successful
when they're opposite sex interactions
and and so so so i believe uh uh that
and then the sensory component too is
something that may that may uh change
uh especially the anxiety component um
when you give them an anxiety relieving
drug like testosterone
and then we're back to like well would
something else be better so so i do
think that that there's a lot a
connection there where where somebody
who lacks social pragmatic understanding
and theory of mind is more likely to
come to bad conclusions about um
why they're socially unsuccessful
yeah and and particularly with autism
where they do tend to feel more anxiety
because
the way they move through the world is
very different it's very difficult for
them like you said to understand social
interactions and if you don't understand
the rules of a game and you're
constantly being fooled to play the game
it's incredibly frustrating and
anxiety-inducing so that does make
complete sense and then they they have a
difficulty in general which i believe to
be on a
neurological level with with transitions
with transitioning and that's that's
kind of infamous for autism they don't
they don't want to move to the next
activity they'll get very upset and
conversations are full of transitions my
turn your turn my turn those are
transitions and if you if you are
emotionally very upset
from transitions if they fatigue you on
a chemical level and and it does with
autism
it's chemically fatiguing somehow they
don't have the the neural structures in
place for that stamina to cope with all
these transitions you know it's it's you
want to have things like a preferred
topic you only want to talk about
pokemon because then it's my turn then i
can just talk and i know what you're
going to say you're going to say oh cool
and then i get to say another fact and
then you say oh cool and then i get to
say another fact and then you know
around and around we go and that's a way
of controlling the conversation to
reduce anxiety and to minimize uh
conversational transitions and and
unexpected turns
um and and uh being trans is another way
of structuring conversations and
structuring friendships for people who
are socially deficient
something to talk about
yeah it's something to talk about and
particularly when you look at
the right of diagnosis with boys and
girls
far more boys get diagnosed with autism
than girls do because it presents in a
far more obvious way with boys whereas
girls
they tend to you know boys are also
genetically different so so yeah they're
more prone to it for for chemical
reasons they don't have a second x
chromosome coding for a lot of things so
they're getting a lower dose of certain
chemicals and so boys develop more
slowly than girls
across the board
but as a result we don't identify i
diagnose a lot of girls have autism so
do you think it could be that these
girls are i think it gets overlooked i
don't know if it's autism specifically
but i do think that the girls are
overlooked for developmental disorders
um that make them uh i guess uh
they're more likely to just be
stigmatized for their lack of social
understanding i believe and and expected
to to figure it out
and and also uh girls tend to be uh more
verbal whether they have autism or not
uh and so that might be a reason that it
gets uh overlooked
some very problematic truth bombs being
dropped here about girls being more
verbal and stuff like that
very controversial i will defend this
hill
well
we will all i think defend this very
controversial hill
hey francis do you like podcasts and
politics no mate i'm a real man i'm only
interested in football birds and fast
cars last time you tried to drive a car
you had a panic attack when you got
overtaken by a granny she was driving
very aggressively and used disgusting
language for a woman of her right well
for those of you who do like podcasts
and politics then you have to check out
the lost debate it's a podcast and
youtube show for political eclectics who
want to escape their media bubbles and
engage in good faith with ideas from
across the political spectrum it's three
friends from across the political
spectrum discussing the big issues of
the day ravi's a former obama staffer
and school principal corey's a former
fox radio news host and ricky's a new
york post columnist instead of being at
each other's throats they focus on
bringing new perspectives to the table
in constructive debates that sound less
like crossfire and more like discussions
between real people they sound like us
apart from the whole sound like real
people bit that and they might actually
know what they're talking about check
the lost debate out on youtube or
wherever you get your podcast
and look the co i suppose the question i
want to ask you is you know we've been
talking about this issue for probably
three years now two or three years since
we first sort of ventured into it
and the more we learned the more
horrified we became as to some of the
things that have been happening
we've had former whistleblowers from the
tavistock clinic here in the uk and and
many many other people on the show to
talk about it since the first time
do you feel like
some progress is being made in at least
slowing the pendulum if not perhaps
getting it to start swinging
back towards the sensible direction um
or you know or do you feel that the
madness is accelerating because it's
kind of hard to know on the one hand in
the uk we see some of the debate is
being had and some of the laws are not
quite going as far as they might have
done and
various organizations that used to be
very powerful and no longer quite having
the same influence on the other hand
every time you open a [ __ ] newspaper
there's some some trans person who's got
quote her penis out in the middle of the
street as we're recording this has
happened right here and the day before
we read a story in the in the prison in
new york a trans woman impregnated
several women and and on and on it goes
so is someone who's paying attention to
this what do you think is happening are
we moving towards
a healthy direction uh or or is it just
getting worse
it's so hard to say i think i've seen
some promising things such as texas's
stance on uh whether these interventions
are abused or not
uh arkansas i think or alabama one of
the one of the a's
just passed a law about it too or is
trying to pass a law so so i'm starting
to feel a little bit optimistic that
some of the states are pushing back but
at the same time
my state california
los angeles which is where i grew up uh
is is either about to or just put a
26 year old man in a juvenile female
facility because he identifies as a
female and he was a minor when he
committed the crime
it's like well he was he was a man he
was he was a man when he committed the
crime he wasn't identifying as a female
when he committed the crime but he's
identifying as female now so he's going
to the female prison and he was a
juvenile so he's going to the juvenile
prison so
they don't have a line they're going to
keep this group is going to keep pushing
the boundaries
uh because because they like crossing
boundaries crossing boundaries is the
point so so if they can get a male adult
male sex predator into a juvenile female
facility that's what they're going to do
and that's what they did they did his
name's hannah tubbs
um there's there's
it's it's it's so so so on the prison
front for instance it appears to very
much be accelerating they're just
they're shoving them in right now and
and uh people haven't woken up yet to
the fact that the of the of the ongoing
horrors that these women are being
subjected to
for the crime of being female while
having committed a crime it is cruel and
unusual punishment especially emphasis i
mean it's obviously cruel but it's
clearly unusual to uh subject a prisoner
to a risk of pregnancy you cannot do
that to a man that makes it unusual
therefore you can't do it to a woman
and
that's in our constitution
no no no no look
i mean
the idea that someone with a male
anatomy is going to be in a female
prison to me
just shows that we have gone completely
off the [ __ ] rails and it's absurd
right
the fact that you've got male
athletes physically male athletes
competing against women including
contact sport
including and it's just absurd and again
shows how fast the fact that we're
transitioning children i mean this is my
personal opinion again
it's
they're not capable of consent
yeah they're not they're not and that's
the thing is that they want to
they're pushing it because they want us
to accept the idea that young people can
consent to radical uh
touching of their genitals
if a child can consent to to having
their penis inverted why can't the child
consent to having their penis touched by
an adult now look i've heard this
argument a lot and it's not an argument
i necessarily reject out of hand but
what is your evidence for that why are
you saying that that is the case
uh why am i saying that is the case well
here's here's an example uh dr marcy
bowers of the wpath uh said on camera
and i am jazz he joked about how jazz
could be a porn star while he was
photographing jazz's genitals
so that in order to get this midline we
need to bring that down more and that
will centralize this i think we're
saying the same thing i'm happy i i have
a good sense of what we need to do let
me just take a a picture too
poor thing you could be a porn star for
all the photos you've taken
god i'm so sorry i did not see we have
to just keep joking around here or
otherwise we don't get through god knows
if we didn't laugh in the last six
months we wouldn't have made it i'll get
dressed again you get dressed again
while he was photographing jazz's
genitals
while he was doing that he was joking
about how you might as well be a porn
star
i i'm sorry he's he's clearly getting a
thrill from this he's he's he's an agp
we know that that's a sexual illness he
likes he likes what he's doing he likes
touching children in this way and
harming them
this is my firm belief the pornography
joke to me clinched it because he made
it in front of the child and in front of
the family
he was trying to see what he could get
away with in my opinion uh and so so my
other evidence for this is that
organizations like wpath are actively
including a lot of fetish information in
in their their publications they're
including information for instance about
castration fetishes and unique fetishes
and specification and things like that
it's in their their actual materials
that they're directly connecting to this
so so um
that's that's that's why i feel like
that is uh behind this uh um as as well
as other other uh statements from
um
just just the idea that you can that you
can consent to these things
is um
but
surely
what you've talked about is like two
individual instances
does that therefore mean that there is a
greater trend across the
across the entire professional or the
people who are treating gender dysphoria
i believe that the people that are very
essential to treating it um are people
that don't understand that children are
children
uh and that are very um
preoccupied with their sexual
development i i don't think that you can
uh
be
interested in protecting children's uh
innocence and sexual development
uh and also be doing this to them
knowing that you were are robbing them
of sexual function in the future
uh so so i i just don't see how someone
could know that this is what they're
doing to a child and not want to be
doing it to the child and and i don't
see wanting to do it for a good reason
because they are taking their child's
sexual function jazz jennings has said
that he doesn't have any sexual
sensation
um he has since in this recent episode
described being penetrated and it looked
like it was quite a horrible experience
for him
i mean the this is a very very difficult
thing to talk about yeah but
the problem that i i have with with the
discussion as we're having it is
we're talking about people who are
transitioning and you know doctors doing
it do you not just sometimes do you not
think that there's a more charitable
explanation for this which is look these
doctors think they're doing the right
thing
you know just in the way the doctors
who who provided
thalidomide to pregnant mothers for pain
relief thought they were doing the right
thing
you know
i i agree with you that some of these
doctors uh believe that they're doing
the right thing and don't know enough
about the drugs they're prescribing to
know what they're actually doing or how
the drugs work oh uh but at that point i
feel like you are you're getting to the
point where where they should know and
when we should have an expectation um
because if they think they're doing the
right thing because they're deferring to
authority figures telling them so so it
is it is the the medical equivalent of
the nuremberg defense i was just
following orders well they could have
done their own research and and they
should have because they were a treating
doctor
and and they're not because they're
right but that's a very different point
to the idea that they enjoyed touching
the kids yeah yeah yeah yeah so so
there's there's the people that are
pushing this initially and are the
reason that it's gone as far as it has
and then there there are likely the
majority at this point of doctors who
are following orders and doing what they
think is the right thing so so i
definitely don't i'm not saying that
they are all pedophiles
because
to me it's it's a very serious
accusation to make against
you know a lot of people who i think i
personally think they're misguided in
what they're doing from my experiences
being an educator and if if my child god
forbid identified in that way
there is no way that i would allow them
to do it but it's it's it's another
thing to then say it's because they get
a sexual thrill from touching it surely
that is a tiny tiny tiny percentage
of people in the medical profession
which you would probably find
in in every profession every profession
there are unfortunately predators etc
right so so when i'm talking about like
the predators behind this and pushing
this that i i agree that it is it is a
minority of the medical profession it is
a minority of the people that are
prescribing this especially now and that
a lot of the people that are behind that
that i would i would class in that camp
are also not medical professionals but
they are the ones who are driving the
policies
uh and are in our um
behind uh the the propaganda and
especially the fact that that it wasn't
more fully vetted that they went jumped
straight into doing these treatments
without actually researching them um if
if they were concerned about protecting
the children they wouldn't have done
that but at this point that small and
vocal and and truly disturbed minority
um has propagandized
the medical field and has captured a lot
of institutions somehow
okay i see so what you so just to just
to be clear uh
what i heard and correct me if i
misheard is that you think there is a
small minority of people who've managed
to
who are
predators in one way or another who've
managed to influence many other people
into supporting their worldview and
their ideology
yeah yeah through through uh carefully
crafted propaganda that influenced me at
one point
i see well it's it's an interesting uh
it's an interesting i was going to say
it's an interesting way of looking at it
it's a way of looking at it that i
you know i we were keen to challenge
because i i think a lot of people like
to throw the label around at people they
don't agree with uh and i think it's
important to remember that you know even
if you're la if you're
if you're making that allegation against
some people
it's not it's not going to be everybody
there might be a small minority of
people who are like that
right right most most of the people who
are pushing this i believe are are
acting in good faith or are
being paid by the manufacturer to just
prescribe a drug and then there's a
small and vocal minority who who is
actually in it for the eunuch fetish for
the castration fetish and we know that
from this very prominent trans
organization that's extremely
influential talking about it
well on that happy note um of castration
fetishes excellence it's uh it's been
great to have you uh on the show to talk
about some of this stuff and you i i
would say particularly
in the first part of the interview when
you know i really appreciated the direct
and directness and bluntness with which
you talk about this issue
because i think that's very important
actually
so thank you for coming on i know that
you are now banned from youtube for
reasons that as always you don't know
because they won't tell you what you've
done wrong uh what what is your
situation now
how where are you with with
you know your your content so so
currently my my content is on both
odyssey and rumble
um and uh can be accessed uh through
either looking for the t channels tt
excellencic or excelanzic.com uh right
now is pointing to odyssey
um and uh so i'm still uploading videos
usually uh once or twice a week uh where
i look at different content i am jazz
series or phalloplasty files things like
that
i've tried to get back on youtube a
couple times but they they keep banning
me
well that's not perfect but we uh we
wish you all the best uh and we're gonna
ask you a couple of questions from our
supporters uh the only they will see on
our locals page but before we do we
always end the show with one final
question which is what's the one thing
we're not talking about but we really
should be
the one thing we're not talking about
that we really should be
oh goodness um i feel like that we are
not talking
and should be talking more about the the
spinal impacts
of binding
and and things about that nature i've
been doing a few videos lately on that
and it's like people talk about the
bindings effects on breast but i think
that we need to talk about the spine as
if it's like the foot and we need to
recognize that if we're putting 13 year
olds in binders they're going to end up
with with deformations
so we need to be very careful about that
extensive thank you so much for coming
on the show thank you so much we thank
you for watching if you have enjoyed
this episode our episodes always go out
on wednesday and sunday 7 p.m uk time
and our raw shows go out thursday friday
and saturday
we also have a podcast if you like your
trigonometry on the go thank you so much
again for watching take care and we'll
see you soon guys
do you feel that if you were brought up
in a culture where female rules are
different would you still have dysphoria
[Applause]
[Music]